Oh back to back playing step by step
again I really don't know what we what
we discuss with when I'm white I usually
am black somehow you controlled I really
own you remember being black against him
somehow sometimes you have this like
against haga this guy who plays be 30
all the time I always have black somehow
that's really weird okay let's see what
we get here yeah this is some this is
not really a good line for black if i'm
not mistaken but wow that's been ages
since i looked at it since i looked at
the line oh now this is downright bad
but but why exactly but should see for I
think it has been played by some strong
players but it's still bad but i doubt
that i remember my analysis ninety two
or a three maybe it's a bit on the slow
side okay let's just develop
yeah I'm porn up that this happens quite
often in those lines in many cases black
has enough compensation I don't think he
does have enough p.m. before is
threatened okay so he actually just
gives me I don't really get it what
happens here I mean before it's still in
the pollution Bishop g5 or Bishop d3 I
can also go be form before Queen is free
BTW xe5 takes on a form but that's not
so convincing we should be five and then
I don't know if I I mean provoking f6
not sure if this is helping me that much
this should be simple and good it's
really just a pawn okay so just you for
now and keep everything come on it's
probably not even the best move
something like 9 p-5 is also interesting
direct a trade show to punish this ok so
somebody six maybe
to also like to play before relief if if
possible okay I go before now is that I
mean it really doesn't matter right also
queen bee three as a movement for queen
before my main concern should be to not
lose this on time again like let like
last game okay I won't lose that that's
another piece laughs resign now that
that opening line is simply not playable
I believe there are lines like that but
not this particular one because I really
can just take who create Bishop c4 and I
think e6 is the best line for black
relatively speaking and this has been
played by some good players but I don't
think it's really good Bishop e6 is also
move but then i think ii for is right
it's been a long time like Harvey here
or something when I looked at this and
its really complicated stuff I mean this
is just a pawn and 44 really nothing
much and you three young yeah after you
five black it's basically lost I believe
ok Bishop g5 is even stronger I didn't
see really why I'm f6 before this takes
a 94 I ok g6
this is very strong yeah engine is of
course right here I mean this is also
very good but the other line is of
course far more powerful I just made
like normal moves and then he stumbled
into into that fork probably being a bit
frustrated by the man opening result
yeah that is not a bad line against the
Greenfeld it's for um I mean the most
informs is very safe white can play this
without risking anything okay well
thanks for watching